hello Richard Welcome to our studio it's
the first time that you are here with us
first of all how do you feel I mean I
know that you played in buwa that you
had to travel to come here how is your
jet like how are you um I don't know I
wish I could uh you know claim Jet legac
and excuse for my poor play so I'm
obviously as as well as I I could be
considering the results but other than
that I'm doing very well of course the
playing call is very nice St Louis is
same as usual so everything is fine here
yes so um I know I mean okay you you
lost this game against Wesley and but I
think you really tried to fight on on
this game and you decided to choose
Kings um Indian like um can you give
some thoughts about it like what did
what went wrong if you can I don't know
I guess um I mean it's not in this month
I mean I lost quite a few games so I
guess uh you know when you're when
things are going um fast yeah you should
probably try to you know U be cautious
and not push too much especially I mean
against wle who is super solid player so
I kind of got punished for that um yeah
what to do I mean but today was a
different game and you played against
Anish uh do you think you got Pleasant
position out of the openings you know
always It's Tricky with all these small
moves like H6 A6 and the and the
consequences like can can you tell us a
little bit about this opening battle
yeah I don't U really know much I mean
about this to me all these Italians are
looking the same thank you I don't know
this is I feel sometimes the same and
I'm like now we play six or later like
what's What's Happening Here there yeah
it's very hard to to say anything so
it's symmetrical position yeah and then
yeah he decided to go for this A6 plan
and B7 I'm not so sure if I I reacted so
principled I mean I think it was normal
game more or less I felt like okay maybe
here I could have played before and I
didn't like Bishop F face which might
not be such a such an achievement for
him after all and after this next
critical moment was okay I think moves
were normal more or less until here and
then I played here A5 yeah which is um
not probably one of my best moves I
wanted to play Queen B3 which I ended up
doing during the game but um I thought
that in this position or in similar
position after
B6 I can go for okay it takes is it
typical this B6 because I was a bit
surprised when they saw it on the board
no I mean it's matter of taste I guess
no because black has this option to keep
the pawn on B7 but it's kind of a small
weakness or play B6 try to play okay he
he's going to play B5 basically play B5
and then try to have this weird
structure which is kind of like no one
is really moving and I think this was
critical moment like maybe I could have
played here D4 I was calculating but E4
seemed like D5 mhm
takes
takes couldn't make this line work for
right I mean obviously I'm not worth but
I couldn't make it work for for an
advantage so yeah um you decided just to
I decided to to play bop3 and then after
this I mean okay the position is about
equal I guess um yeah repetition is kind
of I mean strange a little bit because
but I don't think black is
I mean okay white I feel like it's kind
of normal but also for black I have this
C4 counterplay every time the only
question was what he could go with B4
and before before here mhm in this
position but uh like strategically
speaking but I feel like it's kind of
risky for him because I play C4 maybe
and I could end up with having just very
nice light squares so it's very kind of
normal I mean outcome I think the
critical moments were like kind of early
on in the game and I probably didn't um
yeah seiz the moment so to speak so kind
of sleep yeah yeah I wonder how how much
time it takes to understand all this
consequences of this position I mean how
how many hours did you spend
understanding Italian and all the
structures your life as you can see on
this game I don't really understand
Italian come
on you always say you should ask my
opponent yeah like who knows all all the
moves okay next time we will ask also
Anish what he thinks about it and um
thank you so much Richard and all the
best for you tomorrow it's rest day so
recharge your batteries come back and
show your always creative you know
Spirit yeah thanks thank you and we back
than you Richard and thank you Anastasia
and the